sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas dedicaremos a esta
primera emisión a afganistán y al fin de
20 años de guerra tras el retiro final
de las tropas estadounidenses en tan
solo 11 días los talibanes se hicieron
con el control total del país algo que
tuvo una repercusión directa en las
calles de la capital que se vieron
repentinamente custodiadas por los
militantes talibanes a pesar de sus
promesas de perdón y amnistía muchos
temen lo que será su gobierno el
siguiente es un reportaje exclusivo
desde kabul de kathrein restraint y
sigue el payo
no hay duda de quién está a cargo
omnipresentes en las calles de kabul con
nuevas reglas en la ciudad los talibanes
mantienen un fuerte control en la
capital
epicentro de su nuevo régimen al que
llaman emirato islámico de afganistán
tenemos nuestros líderes tenemos nuestra
nación y tenemos un objetivo lo que sea
que nuestro líder nos pida obedeceremos
todos nuestros hermanos muyaidines
tienen una sola voz todos estamos
sostenidos por una misma mano
no puedes llegar muy lejos en la ciudad
antes de encontrarte con puntos de
control o con combatientes talibanes en
patrullas estos hombres manejan un
vehículo que obtuvieron de la antigua
policía de afganistán que los talibanes
les quitaron cuando entraron a kabul
hace poco más de una semana
y estos hombres avanzaron hacia la
capital desde la provincia de oruzgán
más al sur llenando un vacío de poder
tras la huida del gobierno y las fuerzas
de seguridad afganos la seguridad y el
orden han regresado a kabul no hay más
robos nadie más puede entrar a una casa
sin permiso todo eso ahora está
prohibido por nuestra ley en revisión
hay una amnistía nosotros perdonamos a
todos incluso a los militantes
mientras la vida regresa al centro de la
ciudad las evacuaciones militares
continúan al tiempo que miles intentan
huir
cerca a los límites del aeropuerto de
kabul el grupo talibán muestra otro lado
de su promesa de reforzar la seguridad
anunció que prohíbe a los afganos
acceder al recinto
hay una sensación de que kabul contiene
la respiración esperando a ver la
completa realidad del gobierno talibán
más de 120.000 personas fueron evacuadas
de afganistán desde el 14 de agosto sin
embargo fueron muchos los que no
lograron llegar al aeropuerto de kabul o
encontrar un puesto en esos cientos de
vuelos que abandonaron el país quienes
colaboraron con la coalición
internacional liderada por eeuu ahora
temen por sus vidas el enviado especial
de france 24 cierre el payán fue al
encuentro de algunos de estos hombres
que trabajaron para el ejército francés
y que ahora sienten el abandono y la
traición del país al que algún día
ayudaron un día antes de la retirada
definitiva de las fuerzas extranjeras
las evacuaciones de los refugiados
afganos se dan por terminadas sin
embargo cuántos son los que se quedaron
atrás en un afganistán de futuro
incierto
podrían ser objetivos prioritarios para
los talibanes que ya los buscan porque
ayudaron a extranjeros y eso es una
línea roja para los talibanes con la
ayuda de una red clandestina vamos a
encontrarnos con algunos ex
colaboradores del ejército francés en un
lugar secreto de la capital todos estos
hombres en un momento u otro sirvieron a
francia durante su intervención
recibí este email en el que está escrito
que debo estar preparado para irme con
mi familia rápidamente que la embajada
me iba a llamar y que debo preparar mi
equipaje en seguidamente y todo lo que
teníamos ahora no tenemos nada
fuimos al aeropuerto pero no logramos
cruzar las puertas antes de ir hice
todos los papeles y los envié siguiendo
el procedimiento indicado por el
ministerio de defensa y de asuntos
extranjeros pero la embajada dice que
tenemos que esperar
no podemos salir de nuestra patria
porque los talibanes registran todos los
teléfonos y miran todos los detalles la
situación es bien y mala nuestra vida
está en peligro hemos trabajado para el
ejército francés al servicio del pueblo
francés en afganistán ahora pedimos que
todos seamos evacuados del país recurso
de un tweet o dos post pedimos al
ejército francés que se acuerde de que
un día fuimos nosotros quienes ayudamos
a sus soldados quienes les acompañamos
en sus misiones ahora son ellos quienes
deben ayudarnos no podemos ir a ninguna
parte
estos hombres y sus familias todavía
están aturdidos un día quizás su
sentimiento cambiará pero por ahora
sienten que francia los ha traicionado
una de las mayores preocupaciones de la
comunidad internacional es el futuro de
las mujeres afganas bajo el régimen
talibán un grupo que es conocido por su
interpretación extrema de la ley
islámica de hecho cuando llegaron al
poder aseguraron que respetarían a la
mujer sin embargo dejaron en claro que
lo harían en el marco de la ley sharia
ya que no obstante israel payán fueron
al encuentro de algunas de ellas que
ahora temen por su futuro y su seguridad
una de ellas es activista en derechos
humanos
manejamos hacia las afueras de kabul
para encontrarnos con una activista de
los derechos de las mujeres afganas que
se está escondiendo como muchas otras
mujeres aquí tiene miedo de salir y ha
dejado su hogar habitual por otro lugar
pero hoy ella quiere hablar
esta joven emprendedora educada solía
hacer campaña por la alfabetización de
las mujeres y mejorar la vida de los
niños de la calle en los últimos 11 días
solo ha salido a comprar comida una vez
cómo se siente es que los talibanes se
apoderaron de kabul
es longaray frente a esta inversión
extranjera sin duda tomando esto nadie
que carla no todo está cerca de ablandar
cuando ésta una madera donaldson hay que
versionaron las fórmulas base marca fake
los miembros de su familia se unen a la
conversación incluida su prima de 21
años demasiado joven para recordar la
última vez que los talibanes estuvieron
en el poder pero quien conoce demasiado
bien su violencia de ataques de
excluyan
en
cashman
libertad y unidad de accidente
blanco university world
divergente 4
ella dice que ahora no tiene futuro
está muy claro no hay que creer
hay algo yo el ministro public works a
sumar good
manny
ellie
qué piensa cuando escucha sexto de tu
hija bajo la tajada de los laboristas
mario draghi varón
de hecho ganador en chico de ayer con
anne marie de vainilla o no coman
manifestaron rumba y me dejaron balumba
chin virtual más las se aguanten hasta
notablemente hay menos mujeres en las
calles de kabul desde que los talibanes
tomaron el poder y los lugareños nos
dicen que más usan burka o charlize y se
aventuran a salir
es increíble escuchar a estas personas
que ahora son muchas en afganistán a las
mujeres jóvenes del futuro básicamente
están de luto de un país que hoy en
momento
en la patrulla de talibanes que acaba de
pasar se puede ver en todas partes de la
ciudad realmente es una presencia
imponente los talibanes ahora están
estacionados alrededor del borde de la
antigua zona verde de kabul nos
acercamos a un grupo para preguntarles
sobre sus puntos de vista sobre los
derechos de las mujeres
pueden trabajar las mujeres no sólo van
a la escuela sino también al trabajo
pueden estar en el gobierno si
es así puedes verlo por ti mismo pueden
ir a la escuela pero de acuerdo con la
ley de la charia y siendo ropa islámica
vestido de acuerdo con la ley de la
sharia
y pueden recibir una educación esa es
nuestra regla para las mujeres
estos hombres son soldados de infantería
que esperan la guía de sus líderes sobre
qué roles se les permitirá desempeñar a
las mujeres el futuro de las mujeres
afganas está lejos de ser seguro
y es que la situación de afganistán ha
generado temores de que se pueda repetir
una crisis de refugiados como la vivida
en europa en el año 2015 en aquel
entonces consecuencia del conflicto en
siria en américa latina países como
chile méxico o colombia se
comprometieron a recibir
transitoriamente a miles de ciudadanos
afganos y en la región andina ecuador es
el país que más ciudadanos provenientes
de ese país ha recibido en la última
década muchos de ellos se han convertido
a ecuador en su nuevo hogar y nuestro
corresponsal gustavo ortega nos lleva a
conocer sus historias el regreso de los
talibanes afganistán confirmó haci bulat
javi y a su familia que haber huido a
ecuador hace cinco años para rehacer su
vida lejos del conflicto fue una
decisión acertada escapar de la guerra
el peligro que tenía nuestra familia de
repente yo sentía entonces nosotros
escapamos del peligro javi se dedica al
comercio sin embargo en las últimas
semanas se ha convertido en un
intermediario para tramitar apoyo
humanitario a sus compatriotas que
quieren ir ecuador pero la posibilidad
se aleja luego que el canciller de la
república mauricio montalvo afirmó que
ecuador no podría recibir por el momento
los 5.000 afganos que había prometido
carta suplicando ayuda y copias de
pasaportes ocupan la sala de su casa la
tristeza no embarga por no poder ayudar
a todos como quisieran las mujeres las
niñas yo siento para ellos que siento
dolor aquí en mi corazón eso me motivó
para poder buscar apoyo para esta gente
ecuador es el país latinoamericano que
ha otorgado más visas a los fast canós
455 en total en los últimos nueve años
según datos de la cancillería
ecuatoriana de esa cifra
135 han sido entregadas a solicitantes
de refugio 102 a personas que
necesitaban protección internacional 135
de turismo 10 para visitas no mayores a
90 días 2 con fines diplomáticos 22
amparados por consanguinidad 3 por actos
de comercio y 36 relacionadas a
estudiantes profesionales o trabajo
[Música]
by arabiya bar otro afgano que llegó a
ecuador por decisión de sus padres hace
19 años está agradecido con el país que
lo acogió cuando nosotros llegamos aquí
como dimos al exilio refugio cosas y
siempre fue un trato muy bueno muy
cordial por parte de ellos y como normal
un trámite lo que ustedes a órgano le
vamos a dar otro trato ustedes de otro
lado otro trato no por llevar como javi
ha construido un hogar único maduro y
estaría feliz de que su comunidad se
ampliará en esta nación
sospecha que no ocurrirá porque intuye
que sus compatriotas sólo usarán la
región como un puente para llegar al
destino más solicitado por los afganos
eeuu y américa
gracias por haber seguido esta emisión
de corresponsales nos damos cita la
próxima semana siga con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom